Hello Freak bitches.
So what kind of tattoo are you talking about when you hit 10 million?
It's going get that panther down your neck.
Get something on your neck.
Maybe like an ellipse,
like a lip kiss.
That'd be sick.
Like a realistic one that I liked that.
I liked that.
Tat that tentacles.
And now you're talking nonsense.
Can you try to get that?
That's given me yared towers.
That's 45th.
Yeah.
That's many days.
Five or six days and you have to take time out like that.
That's a Kenyan.
You get your wife to kiss you on the next one.
Hundred percent no to that.
How about if you get one right above your been been been been denied right above
it.
I hold my Dick like,
oh,
I write up about my,
my hammer home at Dick up and you just tattoo another set of balls.
Dicks.
They do get their tests.
They do.
I'm thinking about doing it.
No fuck off.
I want to make it sparkly.
It does.
It doesn't spark up.
If you were going to get your Dick Tattooed,
what would you do?
Have a little ears,
barnacles,
barnacles or warts.
Elephant is around me and make it black.
Of course there.
I'd sleeve it out in dark ink if you could possibly be.
Yeah.
Has any guy ever like done that?
Because I know guys get their entire forms black.
Have you ever seen that?
Like white guys will be a really weird.
It's really weird.
Like they have one color,
one color tattoo and I always wondered if like that's a cover up.
Like they maybe had some shitty tattoos.
I always knew it as a cover up.
Like it was a real bad tattoo,
like maybe a girl or something.
So then they just blacked it all out because you can't cover it up.
There was a famous dude who had that in a band.
What band was that?
Tim?
Rage against the machine.
Yes,
that's right.
That dude,
his whole arms was like all black.
A lot of times don't like recovering addicts get like the black band and they do
how many years and then just go black all the way up to your ankles.
I want something on my back,
like right at the top of my back.
Should have your shockers.
Oh
yeah.
Look at this dude.
I want something over my roots that looks bad ass.
That's very odd.
It would take for to kids.
Who is that guy?
He's from rage shoe.
That looks pretty sweet.
Name Jamie.
Tim.
See he doesn't have a name.
That's a bad ass tattoo.
Yeah,
I like those.
What are those things?
That's from like some Japanese symptom at the tadpoles.
Tadpoles in the middle.
Is that come?
They'll come around a cycle.
It's called Com.
I would get that common.
A Tornado.
I don't have to shave my chest and my arms,
but that's what happens when you come into a garbage disposal and you hit the
button.
It's like a symbol of it.
Hey Man,
dude,
he looks sweet.
I'm not mad at that at all.
It might be the best one I've seen though.
They all don't look like that.
It didn't go too deep.
He went like half sleeve,
like down to like the bottom of his bicep.
It's pretty cool.
He's always wearing armor.
Maybe I'll get to six shooters on my hips.
You don't just get one tucked in your lower back pointing towards your asshole,
but just an arrow.
Fun starts here.
Who are these people to get guns like fighters do near their porn stars?
Porn dns pointing down towards their.
The best tattoos in the game as far as.
Well,
excuse me sir.
Your cheeks are tatted.
This man needs to hit a gym occasionally.
Yeah.
I don't like his body.
Can have the dad bod and you get all those tasks.
If you're going to work on a tattoo,
if you're gonna your body's going to be sleeved out like that's not even a dad
bod.
That's a good luck getting a woman to fuck you so you can become a dad bod.
Yeah.
It's a Vegan body out there.
Sorry everybody to.
How dare you.
I dare you start it now.
I'm gonna get a bunch of pictures of vegans who are shredded.
Going to be very angry at you.
I got a new bit about uh,
seeing a couple of fucking in a hotel room across from me.
Yeah.
It was fucking amazing.
I mean,
I won't do the bid,
I'll tell you,
the story has now turned into a bit.
Get fucking crushes.
I mean it went from you to have sometimes you get a new bit and it can take
three months to become your closing bit because you're still working out this
thing raced to closing bit in like five tellings of it really.
So I won't do the bit,
but I'll tell you the story which is basically near is even Portland.
The hotel is like a horseshoe shape.
So I'm on the 10th floor and I look across into a room and the curtains are
open,
lights are on,
chick is on her back,
legs up.
And this dude who's ripped his fucking out and I'm just standing there looking
at him like,
like this is the greatest thing I've ever done.
Such great things to ever happen.
I guess I slept my bag in my hand and I'm just transfixed and they're,
you know,
they're really fucking.
And then at one point he uh,
he,
he's,
he goes down on one knee,
eats her out,
stands up,
keeps fucking.
I'm like high five in the glass,
like go
and then and so I had the curtain closed because I didn't want them to see me,
but I popped my head through the door.
I looked like a photographer from the 1930 days
and then I started thinking about what it might sound like and this sound,
this where it gets creepy,
creepy year is I leave my room.
I walked down the hall and I stand outside the room and I listen and I hear him
grunting and I hear her go
to my room and I call.
I call the room just watching him waiting,
waiting and he didn't pick up,
but if he did I would have been like,
yeah,
you've been bitten by a box jellyfish?
Yes.
Dude,
I've been stung.
Technical.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'm saying bitten their face.
You've been looked at and read.
You've been read the riot act now they don't have my mouth.
Did you get.
How'd get stung or do you.
Did
you not know what was there?
Like what?
I didn't know what to say.
Obviously I was about 12 years old in Torres Strait,
which is a bunch of islands in between Australia and Papa New Guinea and I was
playing with a holly Patar Strait islanders,
a local boys playing in the ocean,
you know,
just swimming around.
And then I had one wraparound.
My,
my leg quadricep.
Um,
yeah,
a lot of pain.
I've heard a women who've had children have said that and been stamped,
have said that it's,
it's far superior pain to childbirth that superior,
like they enjoy a better or
a far worse,
basically in orders of magnitude worse than childbirth is how they relate the
pain.
You'd probably have to talk to someone who's been stung by a bullet ant,
which is supposed to be one of the most painful things.
I wouldn't wonder who's got the.
She's got to know,
like if you get someone,
listen,
I know you've been stung by a bullet in.
I'd like to encourage you to try the box jellyfish and tell me it's um,
yeah,
it's a lot of pain.
It's a kind of pain where you have to scream expletives,
you know,
you can't just sit there and take it.
You have to be screaming something because it's that painful and it's super
deadly
to the very old,
the very young and the humans,
we get stumped.
Right?
Yeah.
That's,
that's actually pretty good.
We're talking very young five,
six.
We're talking about the amount of toxin to body mass basis.
If you're,
if you're a little tiny kid,
then that's a lot of toxin for a small body mass.
If you're very old,
then it's heart attacks,
aneurysms,
that sort of stuff.
Wow.
Aneurysms fucking messes you up.
The pain.
It causes heart attacks or because you just freak out.
Yeah.
Too much pain.
So just the physical sensation of pain is the catalyst for these heart attacks
and all these different things that you just,
your body freaks out.
I mean,
you aren't getting stung by a neurotoxin.
Don't get me wrong.
There's little in the tentacles of the box jellyfish.
There's new mattresses,
a little tiny poisons,
dots basically.
And when it touches something biological,
um,
so that's why you can wear tiny little thin lycra suit or pantyhose,
whatever,
as long as there's something in between your skin and the box jellyfish will
never seen it.
But if it touches something biological,
then these little poisonous darts,
fire and they fire into your skin and they inject a neurotoxin and it makes for
incredible amount of pain.
Incredible.
And the first day back then was vinegar.
So we had a bottle of vinegar I remember clear as day.
My Dad came over and he got the bottle of vinegar,
two liter bottle of vinegar.
And you just put one little splash on there and then put the lid back up.
And I'm sort of screaming and I'm like,
what the whole bottle on there.
But he,
he wanted to save some in case some of the local got stung as well.
So you could.
Oh my,
it's saving them for some folks he doesn't even know I got one splash
was I was screaming some explainers I'm over that one.
So how long does the pain last?
Um,
it was about six hours before I just passed out.
It was six hours of sitting there screaming,
expletives,
and then I,
I guess I just talked myself out,
you know,
and then I passed out.
I'm still painful for probably about six months.
Five months.
Yeah,
six months.
it,
it lasts for a long time.
Not as severe as that first six hours,
but it's still.
Yeah,
it's,
it's painful.
Six months.
I don't recommend it now.
Oh my God.
That's insane.